-I'm very, very happy
you're here.
I want to talk about the show.
But I want to start by talk--
World Cup time.
England plays tomorrow.
They're already through
to the next round.
Will you watch that game,
though?
Is that very important to you?
-Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
-Okay.
-And I will watch it,
touchingly,
with the same eight friends I've
been watching the World Cup with
since 1982.
-Oh, fantastic.
Does that mean you have to get
to a plane to go see them?
Or are they coming here?
-No, no, they come to my house.
-Okay.
-And we watch it on the TV.
And we -- nothing changes.
We're now in
our mid to late 50s.
And some of my friends are now
judges and heads of banks
and things like that.
But we still, if England score,
we still have
what we call a bundle.
Do you have bundles?
-I -- I don't know.
-Well, it just means you all --
you all jump on top of
each other.
-Oh, like a pig pile
we would call it.
-A pig pile, yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
Of course,
your name makes it classier.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But we have to do it
quite slowly now
because we've all got bad backs.
-Oh, right.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, there's a little bit --
and I'm sure there's someone
who has certain medical reasons.
They can't be at the bottom of
bundle anymore.
-Well, no.
There's always one
who is at the bottom,
because we sort of hate him.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
So, now -- I feel like there
wasn't a ton of optimism about
the English team
going into the World Cup,
but they've won
the first two matches.
Are you -- Are you falling for
it again?
-We have beaten the footballing
giants of Tunisia and Panama.
[ Laughter ]
And the English press
is now saying
this is our year
for the World Cup.
-Yeah.
-You are a bit --
It is, like, it's recidivism.
That every -- You just keep
falling for the team
every year and hope.
And it is --
I mean, it's been since '82.
Obviously, not --
not much has gone right.
-Uh, no. Nothing at all.
-Yeah.
-Nothing at all.
Except, almost every time,
we lose to the Germans,
and we can't this year.
-Yeah, there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's something
to look forward to.
-I know.
I'm so sorry for the Germans.
-You do. You look -- There's a
sadness in this coming through.
-Yes, it's breaking my heart.
-When you were young,
you actually worked at
the Fulham Football Club,
which is a London club.
-Yes, yes.
I used to wash the seats there.
Disgusting job, really.
And dangerous too,
because for some reason,
my work mate was a psychopath.
[ Laughter ]
And I said to our boss,
"I don't think this guy's very
well, you know, mentally."
And he said, "Nonsense,
nonsense. He's fine."
And after three weeks,
he stabbed me.
-No.
-Yes.
[ Audience ohs ]
I have to say I resigned.
[ Laughter ]
-They let him stay on?
-Oh, yeah. He stayed on.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But that's English football.
-You're right, exactly there.
He's got a go-getter attitude
you don't have.
Like, he brought the knife.
-Yeah, quite.
[ Laughter ]
He was the real deal, I was --
-I've been a fan of yours
for a long time.
People have told me
that we look alike.
-I know.
-Yeah.
There's a little similarity,
and I --
-Like droopy eyes.
-Yeah.
We got that nice droopy eye.
And I really --
I will be honest.
In the mid-'90s,
I really leaned into the fact
that we looked alike.
[ Laughter ]
You had a hairstyle
that I thought --
I was like, "That looks great on
Hugh Grant's face.
I'm close enough.
I'm gonna give it a shot."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's, like,
that's, like, pretty...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm very ashamed of this one
because this one,
you looked great and I did
another terrible thing
that you avoided in the '90s,
which is I grew a terrible thing
on my chin.
But that --
[ Laughter ]
That's the one
I feel ashamed for.
-That's awful.
We look like two telephones.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is based on
a true story.
-Yes.
-The show.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And tell us a little bit
about Jeremy Thorpe.
-Well, it was this massive
scandal in Britain in the '70s.
I remember it 'cause I, you
know, I was in my teens then.
And it was just the biggest
political scandal
you've ever had.
And it resulted in
this massive trial,
the trial of the century.
And it was this guy
who was the head of
one of our three big parties --
political parties.
Absolute member of
the establishment.
He went to Eaton, you know,
where the royal family go.
Went to Oxford.
Beautifully dressed.
Very smooth.
Had a family. Had a wife.
It turned out he put a hit on
his ex-gay lover
who was stalking him
and threatening to reveal him.
And it was a really crap hit.
It was -- That was
the very English bit.
It was so kind of
hopeless and amateurish.
You know, the hit man was
an out-of-work airline pilot
who got it all wrong
and used the wrong gun
and shot the dog
instead of the man.
[ Laughter ]
So it was very scandalous.
And it -- So the series is
quite dark, but also funny
because it was just so absurd.
-Well, I will say the -- when I
heard the description of it,
well, you know,
there's a murder trial
and it's a closeted politician.
And, I think, in this fraught
political time we live in,
I just assumed it would be
so much darker.
It is --
It's a weird thing to say.
It is a lot of fun as well,
which is a nice thing to watch
about politics right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
But they are freaks.
I mean, I --
[ Laughter ]
I've spent the last six years of
my life, very unlike me,
getting heavily involved in
politics in Britain.
This campaign I've been doing
about evil newspapers.
So I'm up close with politicians
all the time,
and it's unquestionably true
that they are weirdos.
[ Laughter ]
Who would go into that job?
-Yeah.
-You're not paid very much.
And, really, with that whole
thing, it's true.
It is show business
for the ugly.
[ Laughter ]
Narcissistic, egomaniacal.
-Yeah.
-Sociopathic.
And with absolutely --
and very, very rarely
any interest in the country
or its welfare, I find.
-I mean, you -- so, I mean,
one of the things,
I know you've been advocating
for is trying to stop --
it was the hacking scandal
with newspapers.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And do you at least find that
when you talk to politicians
about that,
that they are listening to you
and hearing?
Or do you feel like it's going
in one ear and out the other?
-No, they listen
and they are on our side.
Completely on our side,
actually.
I don't think I've ever met one
who is really
philosophically opposed.
But that's not how politics
works.
It's one of the things
that's made me so cynical.
Because these big newspapers
are so powerful,
they make or break
our politicians.
They choose our prime minister
effectively.
So when it comes to
these big votes on --
well, let's have a new system of
regulation where, actually,
newspapers do have to, kind of,
print the truth
instead of a lie.
At the last moment, the
government will always back out,
because they have to please
these big tax-dodging bastards
who run the newspaper.
-It's very terrifying.
And I'm glad we don't have any
problems like that over here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, you don't have
those problems.
-Yeah, we don't have those.
It's true.
-No, your press is rather nice.